I'm a big believer in Putin I love  Russia I've been there on many occasions  Putin's a strong and fantastic leader on  the international stage people seem to  think ukrainians are angels they are off  their minds they are mostly Nazis and  the Russians are doing a good job  zielinski is a puppet he was an actor  before you may have clips of him in  rubber in high heels maybe let's play  them to the nuclear boffin and he's  being used as a puppet and installed to  create a situation where Biden gets to  animate the new sort of the industrial  complex and uh personally I think it's  the biggest fast we ever did see  imagining Americans are at all  interested in Ukraine is Bonkers most  Americans couldn't find Ukraine on a map  respectfully and nor should they have to  so that's my point of view and of course  it's the opposite to CNN most lefties  and indeed people who live in my Road in  England who adopted Ukrainian refugees  because they're such good people